hello I'm gav I'm Dan we're the slobo
guys you've joined us in an extremely
harshly backlit Quarry where we've
waited for the sun to hit its lowest
point in the sky so we can use it to
film glass cracks at insane speeds yeah
we're going to be comparing the speed of
the glass cracking to the speed of a
bullet and see how fast they travel a
nice little visual representation yeah
we filmed about this before and we
filmed glass before and we figured out
how fast they are we've always put that
information in the video but it's
usually just a number on a screen and
that doesn't really mean a lot when
you're only looking at one thing it's
going to be next to impossible to fire a
gun and simultaneously break a piece of
glass so we're going to film them
separately and then in the edit I'll
combine the shots together so you
actually see the glass and the bullet
moving side by side and we'll see who
wins we're also going to put some foot
markers on the glass and this is exactly
six feet here so we'll be able to
measure the speed of both of the things
we're measuring we'll also be using the
TMX 7510 because it's a ridiculous Beast
I think on that let's get to it I sort
of started losing my breath as I said
we're gonna be measuring them
[Laughter]
lovely six feet of glass marked by these
poles see how it touches the wood there
oh yeah
oh
I'm not as bad
we've done well there especially on a
table that is um it's not hinged yeah
it's hinged it's just not straight not
straight at all so first of all if you
break the glass I'll quickly save it and
then before the light changes too much
we'll have you fire a bullet above where
the glass was and then we'll combine
them ready to go at around 80 000 frames
a second goggles on yeah gloves on yep
go for it
foreign
okay I'm gonna go and get the gun
ready yep
safe all right which should we watch
first so let's do bullet as soon as
you've got it
[Music]
oh wow
that's cool that's pretty slow
isn't it yeah that's uh taking its time
leisurely Pace there
look at the smoke so far behind yeah
never catch it up all right
look at the glass okay ready yeah
oh it was way faster the glass
annihilated the bullet I thought you
were fast forwarding it for a second no
that's the actual speed that's the same
speed as the bullet in terms of frame
rate
look at it explodes
it left the bullet in the dust see ya
that's incredible
what a great comparison
yeah it just really shows you like it's
one thing like I assume that'd be the
case based on the numbers we were seeing
last time
but it's one thing to see numbers and
then just to see it that's on the same
frame it's like I'm I think I'm right in
saying that the pistol bullet travels
faster than the speed of sound in air
right and the speed of glass cracking is
the speed of sound within glass yeah
because I think in the last video I put
like Mach 3 or something but it's that's
if it was in air yeah but the the crack
is in glass so it's just back one so
technically that means that the glass
cracks at the speed of sound and the
bullet travels faster than the speed of
sound but the glass travels way faster
than the bullet does
because the different speeds of sound
yeah different uh different mediums to
travel through yeah therefore different
speeds of sound through them all right
we basically have our answer from that
footage there but we do have more paint
of glass and we could make better use of
this camera so instead of all this
wasted space from our previous frame
I've cropped the image all the way down
so it's
1280x256 and it's pretty much the exact
size of this piece of glass
slightly assuming that we can't see the
bullet go over the top anymore because
that's cropped away so we'll have the
bullet go behind the glass
and then maybe in post because we know
the glass is faster when the bullet is
around here I'll have the glass play
and you'll see it catch up in relation
to the bullet on the same plane that
might be interesting uh do you want to
see if we can guess take turns in
guessing where the bullet will get to
before it do you know what I mean like
where you have to stop it you mean if we
want them to if we want to land exactly
there at the same time where do you
think the bullet's going to be on the
field but it'll be about here you reckon
there yeah hey let's mark that with a
piece of piece of this
you reckon like here yeah okay I'm gonna
say
I'm gonna do a classic
here price is right yeah
outrageous
absolutely outrageous you mugged you off
there bugged me right off I'm gonna get
behind you
safe God did you hear the noise it made
on the glass yeah I also saw the glass
Ripple did you yeah with the Shockwave
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
we didn't realize this at the time but
this bullet is moving so close to the
speed of sound it's about it's slightly
faster so that means we're effectively
looking at two speeds of sound in the
same frame
[Music]
foreign
I think that was a very interesting
visual comparison
and it's interesting sorry I'm just
using my eyebrow to Shield the sun oh
you've got a big enough eyebrow I do
have some bushy Wings on me trim when we
did on the super slow show we we raced
different kinds of bullets yeah and the
nine mil was like one of the slowest
ones yeah we did be interesting to
revisit this
with a really fast bullet and see if
there is a bullet that goes faster than
glass
wow that would have to be some bullet I
can tell you now I don't think there is
but uh it would be interesting again to
see the comparison yeah but it's so much
it's like an order of magnitude faster
yeah it's so much faster
it's like I said before
me
you know doing this
that speed there is closer to the speed
of the pistol than the speed of the
pistol is to this glass cracking I think
we made that comparison last time we
said like someone's throwing a ball was
closer to the nine mil than the nine mil
was to the exactly yeah well there we go
I don't necessarily think we learned
anything new but it was very interesting
to convert numbers written on the screen
into actual visual comparison yeah
that's what I was going to say it's just
like really nice to see a visual
comparison of what's going on although
hopefully if you haven't seen the
previous videos maybe you didn't know
that a bullet was going to lose to a
glass crack yeah I mean unless you know
the speed of bullets and glass cracking
how could you possibly I only know
because I'm a slow-mo guy
well I'm wearing a lab coat I'm a
scientist yeah hopefully you enjoyed
that video found it interesting feel
free to share it with people who might
enjoy that kind of thing we'll see you
next time and uh subscribe if you like
slimo thank you very much for watching
bye bye now let's do some sunglasses
if you're looking for something else to
watch feel free to head over to the
second Channel where I've just uploaded
a video about our new one petabyte
storage server